dear Microsoft hi hello it's me Jordan
we need to talk about Xbox Series X
specifically we need to discuss how to
use this console generation change to
fix how Xbox achievements work and yes
this direct confrontation is necessary
because if the Xbox one is any
indication you haven't yet recognized
how annoyingly flawed the achievement
system has been since the days of the
Xbox 360 so I'm here to politely but
firmly tell you what's up for the sake
of the series X I reach out to you now
and beg that you fix the numeric system
for Xbox achievements going to the next
console generation it's not like the
entire Xbox achievement system is flawed
we can salvage most of it it actually is
a great system for the most part I love
that each achievement tracks it's
unlocked percentage rewarding players
with a special ping when they manage to
earn one that is less than a 10 percent
completion rate it's also a pretty cool
way of seeing where exactly a majority
of a player base falls off of the game
but to get back to the point of the
matter despite what it does well the
Xbox achievement system is deeply flawed
because of the numeric values you've
attached to individual achievements and
the thing is I wouldn't even hate the
whole achievement gamer score thing if
you just didn't allow developers to
decide the individual numbers for their
games achievements because sometimes
these companies take it upon themselves
to be creative and associate the numeric
value of an achievement to some meaning
for the most part this is fine it's it's
fine and other times it's very much not
fine namely whenever someone thinks it
would be oh so clever to create numeric
values for achievements that aren't
multiples of five so unless you fully
complete a game and earn the traditional
complete score of a thousand points your
overall Xbox gamer score is not going to
be a nice round number this is game
breaking issue for me and no I'm not
exaggerating stop looking at me like
that I've witnessed by Xbox gamer score
become a number that is no longer
divisible by 5 a few times now and each
has been more physically painful than
the last you realize how hard and
time-consuming ly boring it can be
to fix this problem whenever it comes up
Jimmy turtle is the latest game to annoy
me every achievement and doom eternal is
divisible by five except for two darn it
they keep breaking and it's a magic
number
the former Awards you thirty three
points for performing thirty three
unique glory kills in a single save slot
while the latter Nets you 67 for killing
666 demons honestly I don't particularly
like doom eternal I don't want to keep
playing doom eternal but I am still
playing doom eternal why because I want
those thirty three points to be evened
out I have to keep going and kill at
least 666 demons do you realize how
crazy it makes it sound like I'm the
crazy one here and don't tell me to
download and play threes again instead I
won't do it I don't want to keep playing
threes so please Microsoft fix this just
enact a policy that all Xbox
achievements for Xbox Series X games
need to be divisible by five I didn't
want to feel compelled to keep playing
games that I'm done with just so that I
don't begin hyperventilating whenever I
log on and see my gamer scores a prime
number don't worry I'll make sure to
even out my gamer score ahead of the
series X's release I'm sure plenty of
other Xbox owners who care about this
will do the same just help us by making
it easier to keep it that way
Cheers Jordan remain
[Music]